i need uh the two of you to step off for
a second okay and and and uh and we're
gonna bring it back later
yes and we'll tell you why more
information later it's a tease we'll
tell you why in a couple of minutes
so shall i introduce the vice president
yes okay
so vice president
no no okay shall we dance let's do a tap
dance sunny hostin and anna navarro were
asked to leave their seats on the view
friday live on air just before vice
president kamala harris was set to make
an appearance on the daytime talk show
since this is going to be a major news
story any minute now what happened is
that sonny and anna both apparently
tested positive for covid no matter how
hard we try
these things happen they probably have a
breakthrough case and they'll be okay
i'm sure because they're both vaccinated
up the wazoo you know a lot of vaccines
the vice president did end up appearing
on the morning show but virtually
instead of in person we did everything
we could to make sure that you were safe
because we value you so much during her
appearance kamala addressed sonny and
anna's breakthrough cases of covet 19.
sonny and anna are strong women and i
know they're fine but it really also
does speak to
the fact that they're vaccinated and
vaccines really make all the difference
because otherwise we would be concerned
about hospitalization and worse the view
is currently in its 25th season e.t was
on set for the premiere of the milestone
season earlier this month former co-host
megan mccain left the show in august and
joy behar teased what we should expect
we know every week they're going to
bring on another republican we know that
the tv personalities also reflected on
what season 25 means to them and what
it's like being back in person after
working from home for so long amid the
pandemic it's much more fun to have
fewer people i think because you can
talk more and then more people can we
can say more to each other even it it
became like i've got i gotta get a word
in here now you know it was i don't i
don't love that but we've learned how to
do that now um but the opposite of that
was being alone in your house which is
what we were for the past two years and
now it's what we'd be like well what do
you think and then all of a sudden i
have to give a speech i didn't love that
i didn't love that i like the audience i
like the camaraderie i like the fun of
it which is what this is about now today
and this is why the view is popular for
this exact reason